i'm just talking about
drake and the ghost writing kanye has
everything to do i don't care that drake
had a ghostwriter
ghost writers that people could say
wrote for yay or wrote for this one
i could turn around and say but yay
wrote for
jay-z if we're going to do that okay so
now we got to say
jay-z has ghost writers and that's a
whole different conversation
i don't know about it but we don't want
to have that conversation i don't want
to add that call because
i want him to do business with roc
nation and title so i don't want to have
this conversation
but i have to keep it real and tell you
that i have
footage and evidence that kanye west
came in the studio gave him a line
and gave him a song a hook and a bridge
i gotta get these devils out of my life
that's kanye i'm from the murder capital
where we murdered
that's kanye loser for lucifer i did the
beat
that i gave you that i wrote that for
you
that's no different than with quentin
miller differently i don't disagree
but so jay-z don't got ghost writers
play me the kanye reference it's in fade
the black movie
you want me to find a timestamp for you
no i know what's in there i remember i
have the movie on dvd i could go you
just don't want
we don't want to accept that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] right like
this is what i would say i think drake
is one of the greatest artists
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] i don't put
kanye nor drake in the
top mc's like like top ten yeah you
could put them in
top artists exactly now we're talking
about like mc [ __ ] like i can't put them
in that because
because it is very very don't put jersey
in there never
come on man [ __ ] it on
2001. but kanye wrote for him on the
black album a couple of lines on a beat
that he
had brought to him no no no no no no no
no no he gave him
a bridge a hook and lines and jay-z went
in there and said it
word for word now i don't want to say i
will give jay-z to that passage
yes i don't want to say kanye wrote for
jay-z
but if we gonna move the goal post for
certain people
we gotta keep it a buck we got it we got
to keep it a buck
jay-z wrote for bugs bunny on the space
jay-z wrote for dr dre and snoop dogg
i'm aware
but we won't say but we won't say snoop
had ghost writers until snoop came out a
couple weeks ago
and said hell yeah he wrote that [ __ ]
for me yeah but again
why we don't why we don't look at it
like that and i love all these people
i'm not [ __ ] on him i'm just trying
to play devil's advocate like
if jay-z could tell me i mean if snoop
could tell me that jay-z wrote still
d-r-e and like hey that [ __ ] was banging
so i said i want to say that let me i
say that [ __ ]